could history be repeating itself with
raids and overzealous prosecutors
seeking fame and glory in the Washington
Examiner this week mark Vargas cited the
fate of former Illinois governor Rod
Blagojevich of Illinois the Democrat is
serving a 14-year sentence for
corruption
Vargas argued that the governor was the
victim of overzealous prosecution by
then US Attorney Patrick Fitzgerald who
the writer called Jim Comey's best
friend and that it was then FBI director
Bob Muller who in 2008 authorized a
totally unnecessary and ruthless
pre-dawn raid of the governor here with
us exclusively our Blagojevich's wife
Patty and Chicago attorney Len Goodman
who represents the former governor it's
great to see both of you patty your
husband has been in jail for now seven
years of a 14-year sentence he's he was
convicted of four on a couple of
different corruption charges was bribery
and extortion I believe and I think when
people hear that they think oh he must
have taken a bribe he must have promised
to do something for someone giving him
money and he must have been heard or
there must have been documentary
evidence saying all that but in fact
right it's none of that happen no none
of that at all you know Laura for me
listening to your show it's almost like
Yogi Berra says it's deja vu all over
again you know 10 years ago these same
people Comey Fitzgerald Muller used
these out-of-control prosecutors and FBI
agents came after my husband with their
unchecked power to undo an election by
the people they came after my husband
like this these people are so far from
le eliot ness they're a million light
years away and these are politically
motivated opportunists who use their
offices for their own personal
enrichment to further their careers to
sell books pollinate so yeah I don't
think Bob Muller needs to further his
career I mean he's been FBI director
he's you know he's he's esteemed by
Republicans and Democrats however
he also authorized and Lana you can get
in on this he did authorize a raid that
was kind of reminiscent of both mana
fort and Michael Cohen this like
pre-dawn raid the kids are there you
know everyone's shaking they're afraid
and they go want to kind of you know
take everything out of the apartment
same thing happens with you completely
unnecessary of course in a white-collar
case they could have called the lawyer
and rod would have come down and
surrendered to do that to his two young
children was disgraceful and I think
look you know we have to remember that
Patrick Fitzgerald for people who are
watching who goes hey why are you
talking about this guy Patrick
Fitzgerald
well he's representing Jim Comey right
now they're best buddies going back to
the 80s working in the Southern District
of New York there he is he went after
scooter libby outrageous prosecution he
went after Conrad black the core part of
that conviction ultimately overturned by
the Supreme Court and of course not once
but two times they tried lagaya vich and
the court sadly didn't take the case a
couple of weeks ago and they could have
cleared up this ridiculous federal
bribery statute which is extremely
confusing wide enough to you know you
know drive a truck through
and yet he's praised for being oh he's
the most esteemed for something did the
Enron investigation and the Enron case
and but there were problems there too
Andrew Weissman overstepped it without
Arthur Andersen Arthur Andersen ends up
getting you know exonerated meanwhile
they laid off 85,000 people in the
interim so like people here prosecutor
they think oh they're you know there's
their civil servants they're protecting
us in some cases they are but they have
unchecked power often times and it can
be out of control and I'm sorry but as I
speak as a former criminal defense
attorney Len I don't want to be on my
high horse here as you know it's always
the defense is always right it's not but
if they want to get you for something
they will get you it's true and you know
I mean Liguria vich was investigated
they began investigating him early on it
isn't in his administration he endured
he and his family endured five years
of investigation he sat for two
interviews with the FBI because he he
was somebody that believed in the system
and believed that they were you know
interested in in doing right as patty
said he was never never took a bribe
never took a kickback never tried to
enrich his family he's one of the only
elected officials it has ever been
prosecuted for corruption based on
political acts fundraising and doing
political deals they went after them you
know they haven't when the when the
federal government invests resources and
their credibility in making the case
that somebody is corrupt and if their
job is to prosecute they're in and you
come up empty like when you finish the
investigation well the kid oh he didn't
take a bribe he didn't fly in a fancy
jet he didn't take vacations on someone
else's dime but but the court is going
to convince a jury to say hmm he
believed that he might get that he might
have to do something that a donor wanted
him to do that's crazy Bob McDonald got
ultimately exonerated for that right the
states have a battery but I look we
can't really get your whole cold case
tonight but I have to say to the people
watching Bob baller Jim Comey and
Patrick Fitzgerald just because they're
you know they're smart guys who went to
great schools and have done some good
stuff in their careers doesn't mean they
always get it right and if you're
overzealous any of it you have a history
of being overzealous in high-profile
cases we just listed 3 Patrick
Fitzgerald that with the Conrad Black
with stupid Scooter Libby and now and
now his pal call me and they involvement
in this you got to start asking tough
questions and patty I'll let you speak I
know you have a heavy heart and a lot on
your mind but if you could tell Donald
Trump one thing other than pardon your
husband or commute a sentence what would
you tell him about Bob Muller your
experience with what well I mean the I
think the president knows that when
people have unchecked power it's a very
dangerous thing and you know the the
role you know we believed in the courts
and we believed that the court system
was going to work
properly and so if without and
unfortunately our our trust was
misplaced we thought the justice system
was gonna work we believed that you know
people operated and truly and honest
with true and honest motives and we were
sadly mistaken and you know this is
something that he's seen now
unfortunately what we've gone through
ten years ago and what we've been going
through for the last ten years you know
this is if they can bring down my
husband who is the governor of the fifth
largest state for asking for campaign
contributions absolutely no one is safe
in this country not a single donor safe
and not a single politician who has to
ask for campaign contributions is safe
thank you both for being here tonight
telling your story and president thank
you and a litigate litigating the case
and the press is very difficult but at
some point I guess they feel like they
have no other option given the enormity
of the special counsels office the power
they have the manpower they have they
got a lot of legal eagles working for
them and now Trump is beefed up his team
so I guess it's bring it on thanks to
both of you